the situation on the border continues to
get worse and worse and this is driven
explicitly at this point by joe biden's
terrible policy
according to axios the biden
administration kept a trump-era policy
known as title 42
as a tool to quickly turn back adults
and families who illegally cross the
southern border
but according to new department of
homeland security data leaked to axios
it has not been used at all for families
so trump had a policy if you show up on
the border
we force you to remain in mexico while
we adjudicate your case you can apply
for asylum
in mexico you can't cross the border and
just disappear into the interior
that was title 42 but dhs now says that
if you arrive as a family
they're not going to do that in fact the
data shows an average of just
13 percent of nearly 13 000 family
members attempting to cross
the u.s mexico border will return to
mexico between march 14th and march 21st
using the public health order which
essentially says the u.s can close the
border to non-essential travel because
of the covet virus
it's a sign of how the administration is
struggling to keep up with the migration
surge and has recently been hamstrung by
mexico's inability to take in more
families the u.s would otherwise expel
well actually it is not a sign of how
the administration is struggling to keep
up with migration surge it's a sign of
how they are unwilling to keep up with
the migration surge
they're saying let everybody in the same
administration that tells you
that florida is is terrible because it's
wide open and kovid's going to spread
and we're all going to die and keep
masking up
they're not even using the coronavirus
pandemic to reject people at the border
that we have not tested for covid
that's how ridiculous and incoherent
this administration's policy is
the other 87 percent won't remain in us
indefinitely according to axios but
they will be allowed into the us to go
through immigration proceedings which
means they will stay in the us
indefinitely
proceedings can take years the dhs
spokesperson said well you know one week
of stats doesn't reflect the full
picture
our policy remains that families are
expelled and in situation where
expulsion is not possible they are
placed into removal proceedings
white house press secretary john sackey
says the process of deporting those
families sometimes
takes a minute to ensure there's proper
transportation and steps in place
to do that no what's happening right now
is that you guys have decided that you
are just going to let a ton of people in
and joe biden has incentivized all of
this it is perfectly clear
at this point the good news though is
that kamala harris
is happy about it apparently so kamala
harris was asked whether she's going to
go visit the border she's not by the way
kamala harris apparently is now going to
visit florida she tweeted out yesterday
help is here she put out a tweet help is
here she wasn't landing at the border
she was landing in florida
guess what vice president we don't need
you here
in fact the great success of the state
of florida is because we have explicitly
rejected everything you could have
possibly recommended
you're from california the state that i
rejected because they went entirely the
wrong direction
do not come here and bring your crappy
policy here the state of florida voted
against
joe biden and kamala harris for a reason
and it's because they reject the kind of
pal
help is here help is here says kamala
harris yes we desperately
we desperately in florida need the help
of kamala harris an incompetent senator
who couldn't get zero percent in a
california primary before she was
plucked out of obscurity
thanks to the fact that joe biden wanted
a black female for his vice president
we need her help desperately so she
arrives in florida
and uh and she then is asked about
whether she's going to head down to the
border
and she breaks out the joker laugh which
makes perfect sense because this is
super funny stuff guys
do you plans to visit the border uh
um not today
but um i have before and i'm sure i will
again
[Laughter]
where is the batman
it's she's got the worst i mean that's a
bad nervous deck that is it a lot of
people have nervous ticks
that is a bad one she's asked a
difficult question and she starts
cackling
you know oh my god you wonder why the
democratic party needs to wheel around
a not fully sentient not fully alive
human as president of the united states
because all that stands between kamala
harris
a terrible awkward horrific politician
in the presidency
is that old man that's why they have to
just keep pretending that everything is
fine
in biden land because here is the thing
kamala harris as the face of this policy
looks very very different not because of
race or gender but just because she's
terrible at this
than joe biden does okay in any case the
situation on the border again continues
to be bad
the media were barred from the from
these migrant facilities where we now
have a multiple of people who are being
kept
and housed but footage did leak from
inside the migrant facilities project
veritas
got a hold of some of the footage here's
what that looked like
project veritas has obtained never
before seen i'm sorry
photographs of what it actually looks
like inside this facility children
sleeping
images oh my goodness showing people
wrapped up in what looks like metal foil
laying on the ground their face is
covered
why won't the administration be honest
about this why would they show you
these images we have now obtained these
photos inside this facility
now these photos are very very grim
project veritas has also learned these
photographs were taken
in the last few days okay so
if you actually could see the photos
this is why you should subscribe so you
can see the photos
if you actually see the photos they're
astonishing i mean honestly it looks
like a bunch of people wrapped in
aluminum foils
lying down inches from one another
inches you want to talk about a covered
super spreader
event this would be what that looks like
okay and they are being
put don't worry those are not kids in
cages guys this is
happy fun time camp with joe biden it's
all great over there everything's fine
according to biden administration not a
crisis and also everybody should keep
coming but i'll show they should stay
away because it's awkward right now but
also the media
shouldn't be allowed in because if they
see those pictures then it might be bad
for the administration even cnn finally
catching on they say um yeah it turns
out that we now have migrant children
who are essentially staying in jail
cells here with cnn
finally doing its job you have more kids
coming into u.s custody but
just not enough space to put them in
shelter so that means that these kids
are staying in border patrol facility
for prolonged periods of time and those
are facilities
that are not intended for them they look
like jail like conditions
like prison cells with concrete walls
and concrete benches
and these kids are spending more than
the three-day limit than they're
supposed to
according to federal law so the
administration racing here
to find enough space for these kids that
is suitable for them
okay yeah are they racing are they
racing though because i feel like
they're not racing so much and i feel
like if they wanted to make sure
that kids were not along the border they
would reject families at the border
which apparently they are not doing
these turns out families generally have
kids but they're not rejecting the
families they've fostered this border
crisis and every single person knows it
in fact nbc's steve gutierrez said that
migrants say they are now being
encouraged by the biden administration
we have spoken with several migrants
over the last several days andrea both
on this side of the border
and over in mexico and mata morris
mexico that said that they
were encouraged by the change in
administration many of them didn't know
the specifics
of president biden's border policies but
what they did know
is that he was not president trump and
some of them
did feel that now would be the time to
come to the border
so actually that's gabe gutierrez sorry
about the first name scrub gabe
gutierrez the nbc news correspondent at
the border
fully saying that these migrants are
arriving and they are saying they are
doing so because of biden
but don't worry according to the
administration it's not because of biden
everything is totally fine now the media
are finally beginning to catch on to
all of this the media are beginning to
pretend to care
uh so the media have decided that they
don't like the fact that there is now
lack of border access
which is good i'm glad that they have
woken up to the problem that is the lack
of transparency
inside the biden administration so here
are some of the members of the media
beginning to have questions for the
biden administration about why you won't
let us in
here's katie tour from nbc news saying
that the lack of border access is
somewhat disturbing well yeah
it is divided administration kept
talking about transparency and we're not
getting any transparency here
with what is happening at the border
that we have to get those images uh from
a congressman who won't say where he got
those images
um it is very frustrating for not just
journalists but for the american public
who want to know what's going on
inside those facilities those disturbing
images
okay so katie tour calling it out jake
tapper of cnn now calling it out
today we saw this rare look inside these
facilities since the biden
administration has not granted
news media access to the facility citing
coveted restrictions despite the
president's promise and his inaugural
address
to always level with you blocking access
to the news media is not
leveling with the american people mr
president yeah they're not leveling with
the american people they're refusing to
release statistics
and by the way who are you going to
believe the administration or your own
eyes
jen sackey said literally yesterday that
as these pictures were emerging of these
kids sleeping directly next to each
other
and adults by the way sleeping directly
next to each other in large numbers
inside what looked like essentially
plastic bubbles she said don't worry
we're following all the cdc guidelines
oh are you
it looks super safe over there these
kids are tested
uh if they need to be quarantined they
are quarantined we also follow cdc
guidelines to ensure that they are kept
safe
one of the reasons that it took us some
time to
have some of these facilities or some of
the shelters open to larger groups of
kids is because we wanted to follow
those cdc
guidelines but where else in the country
would it be okay
to have 400 people
in a space for 260 during the pandemic
well again peter we're closely following
the cdc guidelines
uh no you are not you really really
really
are not you have said that kids cannot
be in schools
okay kids can't be in schools if they
are three feet or less apart
okay but you are keeping these kids
inches from one another and it's totally
fine
which suggests this is not really about
covert on the one hand and also they
just don't want to do anything about the
immigration problem
according to the washington post over
the last three weeks the average number
of teenagers and children crossing into
the united states without parents has
stopped 550 per day
border officials are on pace taking more
than 17 000 miners this month which
would be
an all-time high this is obviously a
crisis
biden has a has had a markedly different
approach than his predecessors to an
influx of homeland that
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas said was on pace to be the
largest in the last
20 years 20 years so far they're just
adding capacity to shelters and other
facilities to absorb the influx
declining to implement policies that
would send minors back because the
administration considers the policies
morally unacceptable
which means they want this to happen
that is their goal
which suggests that it's all about the
agenda it's all about the political
agenda
just keep letting illegal immigrants
into the country and everything
will be fine and by the way this is the
same administration that said if you
come after january 1st we're not going
to simply amnesty you does anyone
believe that including the illegal
immigrants are crossing the border
of course not facts don't care about
your feelings and it's a fact that the
ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content